Since we are in New York,
I thought I'd invite a very familiar voice.
He's the voice of the New York Subway System.
You hear him.
(cheering)
You hear him on all the trains
and you hear him on the subway platforms
and I wanted him to come out and just say hi.
Please welcome Charlie Pellett!
(cheering)
Hey!
Hiya, Charlie.
Wow.
(cheering)
Charlie, you have an iconic voice.
Lay it on us.
You know what we want to hear, lay it on us.
Stand clear of the closing doors, please.
(cheering)
That's fantastic,
but, Charlie,
Charlie, this is New York.
That's way too polite.
If you don't mind, say it like a real New Yorker, just once.
You want to hear that?
I say do it.
Stand clear of the closing doors, please, or don't.
Let's be honest,
a guy with his head stuck in the subway doors
would be pretty freakin' funny.
All right.
(applause)
This is why we have you.
Before you go,
I thought of a couple of other phrases
I've always wanted to hear in your voice.
Do you mind?
Can you do it right now?
Next stop, funky town.
Hey girl, you up?
Just a reminder, we're all one day closer
to those big closing doors in the sky.
If you're taking this eastbound seven train to Citi Field,
let me save you the trip.
The Mets lose!
Yeah, yeah.
Stand clear of the closing doors
and stand clear of your mind closing its doors,
because life is a circle, time is infinite,
and you have both never existed
and always existed.
(cheering)
Charlie Pellett from Bloomberg Radio
and New York Subway.
Thank you, sir.